did you see the little fighter in the
kids surprise
little little fighter in the kids
surprise i thought i was going to be
done with these but i had to bring this
one to the show because well
how about i just play it because your
face is
just
i want to talk about your weathered face
yeah you get a little skinny here bro
yeah you are you skinny you know what
the diet is what stress
all right because i know what's that
diet i
i was in dallas i went to dallas do a
little loud look
who came back the prodigal
son returns also can we get some cheese
fries to the table please
table five some potato skins please yeah
what's so uh
him so how do you think this played out
dude that's what i've been all i haven't
wanted to do
i think brendan was the one that
probably was like hey you should come by
man come on the show sometime
uh-huh cause he's hurting and uh he
needs brian callum or the brian kelly
needs him
well i think also that but brandon
overreacted with the brian thing because
what he's noticing is brian callum's
been on a bunch of different shows like
he's been going on [ __ ] crowder he's
been going on
he was also in that uh that really it
was a very little known movie
that came out last year joker i haven't
heard of his
[Music]
was it good which by the way i know we
[ __ ] on callan and all these guys all
the time but like
even though it was a small role and he
was barely in it you got to be in joker
which is like of course
if you're working in any comedy scene
that's you're you can big dick everybody
for like at least a year just on that
one credit
can i say and i'll say this unabashedly
i have a newfound respect for callan
after seeing what this show is like
without him
oh yeah it's it's it's it's un
[ __ ] watchable so brennan
panic as he wanted to keep his uh he
wanted to keep his um
sponsors so he he overreacted and what's
happening is is that
the whole cancellation of brian callan
didn't go as planned no one's really
talking about it
it kind of seems like like we said when
this first came out even though we've
made fun of callan
that it kind of seemed like this woman's
story was kind of [ __ ] now whether
it is or not i don't know but
at least from reading it it seemed kind
of just [ __ ] one of those regret
sex things yeah well all account but
that was the thing like with dalia there
was some concerning stuff that was
coming
out that most of the end up being
[ __ ] but it was more leaning towards
the underage stuff whereas with callan
it wasn't it just like he's just kind of
a pig
yeah and it's like well he was a normal
you know what he was
every day it was a stand-up comic in the
early 2000s dude
let me tell you something the disgusting
[ __ ] that we did in
like 2007 2008 and 2009
even at a small level just running a
couple of rooms and i have an open mic
dude trust me there are a lot of
disgusting human beings in the comedy
scene so they kept uh they kept saying
that he was
gonna get canceled and he didn't and
he's been going on a bunch of shows he's
been
he's he has his own podcast now and it
seems to be doing well
so uh i don't know man with crowder okay
and um was it louder
it was louder you faced on me from hold
on hold on is brenda's shop doing dip
now for real
and also why but i didn't look like dip
though it looked like he was
putting like an edible in his mouth or
something no but it's it's from is it
different from here
why he looks like he's dipping why would
you do that during the show
that's the thing i don't get like if one
of us did that during the show the other
one would be going you gotta stop you
gotta stop stop doing that it's disgus
first of all it's disgusting you're
spitting tobacco chews all over the
place but then also on the air it's like
eating
it's like the oh god we're going through
the chocolate and you're like you take
the thing out of your mouth
where is he spitting too by the way or
is he just swallowing the he spits on
the
colored people's faces yes brandon has
no risk those aren't colored people
though he speaks
he says it all the time yeah on stage he
does [ __ ]
he calls them boy and it's it's a lot of
echo
what's going on with your face
are you talking about this oh i dip now
i dip now hey have you ever seen
so i dip now which goes to show you
something else that i think it should be
brought up
brian callan hasn't watched a second
of this show since he's been off i don't
blame him no no no
no i don't blame him but i'm just saying
you could tell he hasn't
mad for something yeah it should hey
have you ever you're dipping while
you're
podcasting now oh yeah come on stop it
[ __ ] stop because i've turned the
corner i'm i'm i am i
really turned a car on buying look we
have to be man enough to admit it and
i'll be mad enough to admit it right
kind of rules i'm kind of liking brian
is anybody else guys i'll leave you to
the chat room is anybody else
thinking that brian counts uh maybe this
leaving thing made him cooler
cause i'm kind of digging brian callan
now like let's all calm down right
because he's still brian count no no no
no i'm not saying he's a comedian he's
still a ceiling to how cool he can be
of course but his stock has certainly
gone up
yeah you know if you got in on brian
callan stock last
year when he was getting metoo'd
if you'd got in early during the dip you
know what i mean you would have made a
lot of brian gallon bucks
on brian gallon's stocking comedy and i
think it just you know i think honestly
it's not even so much that brian callan
is okay but
it's a matter of how bad this show
really is without him on it
you know and it was bad with him on it
but you know i think
it was mostly because of brendan for the
most part it was brennan well brendan
has no one busting his balls now
that's the thing i know these two are
afraid at least broke each other's balls
a lot yeah
so that you can kill a lot of time with
that amusingly whereas yeah these other
guys are like
damn man yo you're right you're right yo
let's pull up those instagram models and
look at them man
hey yo man she got some nice titties huh
that's all they do whereas callan
immediately came in and was like what is
this now you so you're doing this during
the show
like that's great you know what like
it's just
being a real brian callum now isn't as
negative as you know now it's a
compliment
yeah now when we go you know what it's
it's you know what we'll make it our
real ass dude
is going to be the brian who's the brian
callan on the way
this is the real brian county brian
callan of the week
yeah welcome welcome to the show
i should change it you know what put
them over the edge because
what's up with these two things you guys
sitting next to you what's that about
what is how do you uh i'm a big
fractions guy how do you do six tenths
oh i guess you round it back down right
three fifths
yeah i guess
and i was like this is a very black show
it was me just all black guys
yeah yeah friend was doing this
i'm not gonna lie he looked good
a lot of people think he's you know he
he oh my god leave the camera alone
[Music]
x mine women yeah that's true
yeah what they what oh my god you're
right stop it
and then it's like listen can you at
least first this is well done
can you not afford one of those like all
right like all right so there's
there it's clear that they have like the
kind of tripod that we would have
yeah that's like a little cheaper but
it's like you guys can't afford one of
the
nicer ones that may cause may cost like
five six seven hundred dollars but
it has the smooth pan and it has the
you know what i mean they just they're
just jerking this camera around on a
cheap tripod and it's
bothering me he he and you know you know
this goes to show you something else and
this is something that
not a lot of people catch but catch this
it means that brian callum didn't even
show up early enough before the show
to get the camera shot set correctly he
showed up
by yeah i'll pop up exactly i'll pop by
we'll see what's up
i got it i got to do another show later
though so yeah i got to do the crowder
thing and
i'll be honest with you he's bigger than
you guys so so
sorry which he is which is like yes he's
objectively bigger than brendan job's
show
not well documented yeah now um well i'm
a little skinny because
got to dallas and all of a sudden it was
a blizzard you understand oh yeah
couldn't find a car to rent or anything
else
and then i got to my hotel room and
while the power went out
and there was no heat yeah not even
yes he just said dallas
texas was j.r there
cold power outage
he's a child he's just yelling out words
it's the stupidest person that's ever
lived brendan thinks that he's getting
quizzed so he's yelling out the answers
he's a literal he's steve carell an
anchorman
yeah he is that's what he is
[ __ ] what in dallas it was on it was
the outskirts and then there was no heat
and then i uh and then so heat
texas that's by oklahoma right in mexico
it's like in between
you know look at look you want to see
brendan's face you want to see his face
is like you know why his face is like
that
the alpha dog just stepped back into the
room he was the alpha with these two
dudes
and then all of a sudden callum walks in
and everyone's like oh yeah look at
callan
and brennan has the hello darkest mile
front plane in his head right now
except some sort of like [ __ ] weird
like trap version that he probably
listens to
so i i had to eat pringles in the dark
and all the restaurants were closed and
i found a mcdonald's don't eat
mcdonald's
do you even play no he doesn't eat i
don't but i never
was because i was starving and there
were 36 cars
in line because the only thing it was
the only thing over yeah bruh
so fascinating i can't i could i'm so
glad talen's back though
because when callum being back are we
figuring this out it's like it's like a
science experiment
it really highlights the stupidity of
brandon brendan shop
because the other two yeah brendan
you're so smart but callan's actually
quick you know yeah mcchickens yo
that's all they would be saying but like
brandon is what
mcdonald's is that the uh you mean
the world famous uh burger chain can
can you get me mine with the toy a boy's
toy
no i'm not going to mcdonald's now
brandon you're going later then why did
you say it
can you stop by the gas station and get
me a can of skull
[Laughter]
oh i got a dip he would be a skull guy
he can't even spring the extra for the
copenhagen no he's a skull guy
guaranteed even lower than school like
big bear
one of the ones you find in a at the
back of a race truck and then if you
can't find any of those just buy me some
uh
buy me some white owls and i'll take the
tobacco out of those and just stick her
down on my lip
what'd you get daddy so daddy didn't get
mcdonald's daddy went home oh yeah too
long away
i'd rather starve and then i tried to do
this i tried i was like you know what
you're hungry you're in the dark
i'm gonna meditate oh yeah oh yeah cause
your stomach goes you know what
we're not hungry yeah watch watch
watch how it went i went like this
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it starving meditating hi
cat
oh wait chin what up bro i'm gonna skip
ahead just a little bit
he you know where i'm at i'm calling him
daddy of course
so he is like when you when this reminds
me of like
like even back when i used to like
manage a club or whatever and it was the
cooler manager that left
and you like replaced him or whatever
and now he's popping in because he's in
town for a day and he's coming to never
drink it
everyone at the club is like oh my god
so-and-so's here and you're like
that's cool it's cool the cool the cool
dad's here
i guess nice cool he brings me here
what's going on cat how are you that's
great
and i'm like you don't want to make
secure at all
this interview better is if callan kept
looking at his watch the whole that
would have that
i mean that would make it the best yeah
no sorry it's i gotta do
uh some other stuff later so i'm doing
that to
bert kreischer thing later yeah yeah
yeah but
yeah you guys said looks great take
whatever you got
chemical engineering give me anything
whatever geology
how about astrophysics i'll take it
whatever i'll take if you took a couple
classes astrology
anything sure um and what i get is i go
now
what's your educational background and
immediately go well if you're going to
ask me if i have a paper from some
[ __ ]
institution yeah okay so there we are
there you go so you've done your own
you are a what is web salute they all
say this they all start with this they
all say
they all say i didn't i was i didn't
start as a conspiracy theorist i didn't
start
believing in this but i started looking
into it and then that means you were
educated by that confirm your bias yeah
the watching calen come in
and just run books over all of them over
all of them just
over all of them this is this is
embarrassing it's
this is rough to look at look at shop's
body language
i know you're excited brian i'm yelling
everybody's yelling it's give me you're
making me
you know it's making me jealous that's
why he came on the show
promoting jacksonville by the way he
noticed that um
notice brian callan's markets have
shifted a bit
jacksonville and omaha dude this is a
big when you think of comedy towns
that's what i think of you notice
how much it's changed though like if you
look at brian cowan's old schedule it
would have been all these like hip
cities
and now it's now he's doing the crowder
circuit
jacksonville florida omaha frank
virginia beach
all the hip cities are closed well that
too yeah true
but i mean there's still hipper cities
in florida you could be doing
like tampa yeah jacksonville is an
indicator that
you're doing the crowder circuit six
i know dude that's the problem
when i see jacksonville like i go i go
tampa
spokane i go i go tampa spokane
cleveland miami you have you been to
jacksonville
i've not done it yet you haven't i
haven't done the club no that comedy
zone's new
yeah i know it's been around 37 years i
don't know that
they used to be a restaurant they
changed the coming zone right i
guess the only time i went to jackson
was you and me when you bombed in front
of tebow's
oh boy he told us that he told her that
story
well because they were children yeah
literally on their last breath
it doesn't make me feel funny i got i
got dick jokes and i got you know they
prayed and then brought brian up like i
feel like
it's a bad order maybe you should pray
before the meal gets
well let pregnant operate let him let
him work i'm trying man you know i'm
really trying i'm trying to let them
operate
laughing from the guys the
minority guys
but you're very strong thank you you're
very strong you're probably more
explosive than brendan
so if you really trained i think you
might get him on squats
yeah he's he's built for squads yeah
yeah
do more of the gay talk papa where did
the [ __ ] thighs pop out they got to
see the thighs
artificial as [ __ ] i might have been
using air quality
but i'm going back to that because
that's a [ __ ] good looking guy right
it's a great looking dude
for hams.com promo code shop so if you
want to look like brian there
poor hands beforehand oh my gosh
dude what does he do with the craziest
questions
nobody but like japanese boy has ever
heard of no there's some
uh 80s babies out there like hell yeah
suddenly on the screen
uh those are their producers but they've
been their producers for a while
you should finally we're talking about
shoes
yeah no they don't that's how they built
it disappointing it's cool though yeah
you can't eat it that's dope okay is it
is it dope brendan you're [ __ ] dope
regular piece of cake though huh it's
currently snowing like crazy over
in uh the ukraine and there is a man
who's
uh uh the ukraine sorry to ukraine
it's just it's right next to the russia
house was
obstructed by a bunch of snow he
couldn't get in or out and he didn't
want to plow the snow himself
so he had the genius idea to call the
ukrainian police and say that
he admitted to stabbing his mother's by
the way she she likes to let those
[ __ ] sweaters oh yeah she got him out
there
yeah yeah she's not in dallas that was
real dude i couldn't tell you from this
angle
asian chick with titties like that good
for her pretty cute for an asian chicken
healthier
so they start drinking tequila so now
you start
all right imagine that that's what
people are doing basically
they want to base off the sprinter yeah
because that's what all like musicians
are using now yeah those are luxurious
and they haven't trick them out yeah
they're sick yeah i love it you've seen
the babies one
no oh i missed that you're gonna get
that brian
100 yeah i'm feeling like i'm so scared
of the world yeah like i want a i want
something that can go
you could be van guys son you can do it
i'll be a fan but i want my guns i want
my food
i want i want my water purification kit
i want my first aid
oh you you'd be a weird van guy i'll be
weird van gaal yeah i want my
my lentils and my rice yeah
oh how about this what so there you are
this this survivalist was talking about
all these guys are buying guns right
you know in case you know i think it was
in the story this is
just recently yeah there's like a couple
of okay we're good then all right go
what's your thing go for it
i'm done i can't can we can can i can we
done with this
i was done with this done okay yeah i
can't
what were they pulling up i can't quite
i [ __ ] i just was playing just
a baby's instagram account so they could
the black guy could show brendan shaw of
his cool
tour bus is it cool
is it a cool tour tour bus i
i i'm i find it bizarre
how the window for being like a giant
child
just keeps getting longer and longer
like these dudes are in their like late
30s
did you see the baby's jet bro you're
such a good rapper i just
you're just scrolling you're shut these
sneakers out in these rappers planes
and it's like yeah you're you're
scrolling through other people's
instagrams like i don't know man
like i'm not gonna claim to be a very uh
highbrow person
but like these guys act like
15 year olds you know it's not like like
we're all a little immature in our own
ways and stuff but these guys act like
literal
teenagers it's like yo check them
sneakers out yo
yo man did you see the other day
when megan the stallion show did you see
the shoe she had on bro and the gold
chains it was so cool
it's like what yo did you see the new
fast the furious movie dog that [ __ ] was
so tight and it's like
you're all men in your 30s brennan
brendan is somebody that would [ __ ]
love the fast and furious movie yeah and
like i get
it i'm i'm flawed too i have you know
maturity issues in certain ways but
i would be embarrassed if being rice
were doing entire shows about sneakers
and [ __ ]
cool fast and furious yo man yo did you
see the new uh uh
mazda concept car in that movie bro she
was so tight
it's like it's really like 15 year olds
hanging out and going like like you
might as well have car posters on your
wall and
that's true someone says maybe their
crowd is just 15 year olds it's possible
you know they're also they're also
californians so they wouldn't be saying
bro anymore they'd be saying bro
i get what you're saying but the crowd
is 15 year olds because they're
genuinely into all that [ __ ]
yeah so it's like yeah you're attracting
15 year olds because you
talk and act and discuss things that 15
year olds are into
as an adult ah the old crystalia
yeah it's just weird like i would be
concerned if
most of the people that watched us were
like 14 and 15 i'd be like what are we
doing that's
making these weird young people watch us
like it shouldn't be